welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the latest eternals promo clip
released by marvel studios just revealed
what may be one of the most norm
breaking and hotly debated elements of
the film take a look at this latest
trailer clip from marvel to promote the
film ahead of its release which shows
the moment the eternals icarus and
cersei reunite with fast dose and meet
his son dad that's superman with the
cape and you're shooting laser beams out
of your eyes
i don't wear a cape well what superman
in the marvel cinematic universe aha
from the mouths of babes fourth wall
breaking references that he wrote the
fabric of reality this kid in the mcu is
aware of superman the front man of dc
comics supposed to be a separate
franchise which aside from some weird
crossover comic story lines in the past
dc and marvel never acknowledge the
existence of each other in their stories
but presumably from media that this kid
consumed his go-to reference for a
flying caped superhero is not doctor
strange or thor or vision but superman
this kid now while this seems like a
throwaway joke it was probably intended
that way i can confirm having had the
luxury of being able to see the film
early and i promise to divulge no
serious plot details in this video other
than the material marvel studios has
themselves revealed in their promotional
materials that this is not the only
moment in the eternals film that pulls
this kind of move i won't say what the
other one is only to say that this
superman shoutout is part of an
intentional move by the filmmakers to at
least acknowledge the existence of dc
properties as pop culture within the mcu
it is unprecedented it's pretty weird
but it does tell us something about how
marvel plans to approach the boundaries
of their universe going forward now you
may be saying oh come on the mcu
references other ip all the time in ways
that are kind of confusing if you think
too hard about them true star wars has
been cited repeatedly in the mcu as one
of the titles steve rogers lists in his
notebook and captain america the
winner's soldier peter parker is a huge
star wars nerd referencing the empire
strikes back in civil war hey guys you
ever seen that really old movie uh
empire strikes back in spider-man
homecoming peter and ned play with star
wars lego sets and a little emperor lego
man peter also references the alien
franchise when he attacks ebony ma in
infinity war you ever see this really
old movie aliens one division made
malcolm in the middle in actor brian
cranston mcu cannon along with pretty
much every other sitcom and sometimes
these references create weird plot holes
like tony stark calls thor lebowski an
endgame one side there lebowski of
course reverencing jeff bridges in the
big lebowski but jeff bridges also
played tony stark's nemesis so but i
stain in the first iron man film so who
did tony stark see on screen when he
watched the big lebowski and cached that
clever reference did a different actor
play lebowski in this universe look
there are a dozen of these paradoxes and
ultimately they're really just jokes and
movies they're meant to be fun shut up
nerd says all of our older brothers but
this superman shout out in eternals is
in a separate category in my opinion the
mcu almost never references dc there was
literally one exception and it's a thin
one there was a line from happy hogan
and iron man 3. now you're off with the
super friends i don't know what's going
on with you anymore yes super friends
the wonderful retro justice league
cartoon now you could argue that happy
could have been using the term super
friends as just a common term and not a
direct reference and with john favreau
off screen for this line it does read
very much like a throwaway ad-lib also
in a movie that several fans do argue
about it's true mcu interconnectivity
with tony stark's supposed retirement
and the film's treatment of the mandarin
i am the mandarin
but other than that no dc has been in
the mcu until this superman mentioned
now it's probably less out of any
inter-company rivalry than out of just
basic world logic like think about it
would a world that has famous
superheroes flying around it still
considers superhero fiction to be a
marketable escapist fantasy to the same
extent that we do in our world probably
not right like it's fun to see amazon's
boys explore this subject but i just
don't buy that people would be actual
murderous crime fighters and movie stars
at the same time now sure fiction
inspired by the characters in this world
makes sense like captain america comics
and trading cards distributed as war
propaganda and now collector's items as
well as movies and documentaries
reflecting mcu global events as we saw
in peter's flight movie options and far
from home and the mcu has hinted that
the mythologies of our world are
inspired by this world superheroes like
thor and odin appeared in a children's
book indeed this is what the eternals
film is really all about characters like
finna icarus and gilgamesh are implied
to be the origins of the classic myths
we learn in school now if you're like me
and you spend a lot of days staring
intently at screens like this you might
notice your eyes start to feel heavy and
you can have problems sleeping well blue
light damages our eyes and leads to
digital eye strain symptoms of digital
eye strain include blurred vision
headaches and dry watery eyes for some
folks this can affect your energy level
well thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video blue blocks was
created to fix this problem and block
out the blue light with high quality
lenses
blue blocks are evidence-backed and made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia the founders were unhappy with
the quality behind leading blue light
blocking glasses brand so they made
their own these are great they have over
40 styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers they really just have frames for
every need and already i start to feel
my eyes relaxed i am literally
surrounded by like 20 different screens
i'm like the operator of the matrix
right now so to get yourself a pair of
these just go to blueblocks.com new
rockstars or just click the link below
and you will get 20 off your order and
get free shipping worldwide on orders
over 115 dollars so get your energy back
sleep better and block out the unhealthy
effects of blue light with blue blocks
that's b l u b l o x dot com new
rockstars or just click the link below
code automatically applied at checkout
for 20 off and thanks again to blue
blocks for sponsoring this episode it's
also been implied that the canonicity of
the world of the mcu and its history as
far as what the general public of that
world knows to be true really followed
our history in pop culture right up
until 2008 when iron man went public now
since then the mcu has had different
political leaders different technology
different pop culture they don't really
reference the more modern stuff but they
do reference things like beyonce adele
ben and jerry's ice cream the war on
terror but you could say all of those
things weren't known before 2008 and of
course superman existed long before 2008
as well but for this kid to know of
superman as a reference that he would
make in the year when eternals is set
either 2023 or 2024 this world must have
continued producing superman comics and
tv shows and films for years and years
even after the idea of flying alien
superheroes and patriotic garb wasn't
really escapist fantasy anymore it was
just their day-to-day life that they
were living or maybe the kid just says
really retro taste in comics either way
i think it is fascinating that superman
now exists in the mcu and i think it
tells us two things about the way
eternals is warping the cinematic
universe first the mcu of course is
approaching a multiverse where the rules
of canonicity for everything are
mattering less and less like star wars
ships are showing up in the collector's
garage and what if evan peters is
cameoing as a wink to himself zombies
can catch characters completely off
guard despite zombie fiction like night
of living dead being a halloween classic
screened in this world somehow this is
happening and of course deadpool is on
his way and this guy is an equal
opportunity satirist who references
marvel and dc and everything in between
but second takeaway and this interests
me even more is that the eternals is
suggesting that all forms of media all
parts of our culture has their roots in
the gifts given to mankind by the
eternals and by extension by the
celestials like another detail we found
in an earlier trailer months ago the
holy grail the same cup design from
indiana jones of the last crusade is
among makari's hoarded artifacts now
makari could have moved real fast to
steal this holy grail movie prop from
some hollywood warehouse but with the
other real-life historical artifacts
among makari's collection i think this
is implied to be the actual cup of
christ and that the idea is the eternals
could have been moving these legendary
artifacts around the world throughout
history which resulted in them being
depicted this way in popular media i
mean kingo is the guy who ends up
working in the filmmaking industry and
the same could be said for dc comics and
the superman character superman was
created by jerry siegel and joe shuster
as an american response to the way nazi
propaganda exploited the nietzschean
ubermensch philosophy uber wrench
translates directly to superman and now
i think the idea is that this type of
media superman comics was an outgrowth
of union archetypes rooted in
mythologies that were all sparked by
these eternals for better or worse well
worse considering bastards of crying on
the ashes of hiroshima it's looking
pretty dark so while the mcu is becoming
a more chaotic place it's also
suggesting that all of this chaos has an
origin and a purpose you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you